[Music]
prisoners from India no penitentiary
taken to a local hospital dozens of them
were hurt after a shootout at the prison
located in the city of 1re around 450
kilometers away from Caracas relatives
were anxiously waiting outside we want
to know what really happened to our
relatives we've been waiting since noon
and we still don't know anything
human rights representatives have not
turned up or anything like that we want
to know what happened
pictures shown in local media showed
dozens of inmates dead the government
says they were trying to escape but
human rights groups say they were
protesting for food and want a full
investigation into what happened since
venezuela imposed a lockdown to prevent
the spread of kovat 19 bizza ting rights
have been suspended prisoners rely on
their relatives for food and medicines
but it's not just in Venezuela and rest
has been on the rise in Latin America on
Saturday in Manaus the capital of the
state of Amazonas prisoners kidnapped
seven guards then set the prison on fire
authorities say they were trying to
distract security forces to dig a tunnel
and escaped the incident lasted for
about five hours this operation was a
success we had seven hostages and all of
them are alive there were no casualties
on the police side and and the inmates
there were people injured but nothing
serious
violence is a regular occurrence in
Brazilian prisons as rival gangs fight
for control but the situation is
different this time prisons in Latin
America are overcrowded and lack
sanitation are taking time bomb for the
spread of kovat 19 what's going on is
that prisoners are afraid because
prisons are overcrowded and the
conditions are bad in Brazil for example
there is no running water so how can you
ask inmates to wash their hands
restricting visitors is also problem
because it's a lifeline for inmates that
depend on them to get food hygiene
products human rights groups say
reducing overcrowding is needed to
reduce the spread of disease but it
poses a major challenge for countries
where resources are already running
short teresa waugh al-jazeera